[Musique]
oui bon roman c'est pas d'actu mais si
on me propose quelque chose pourrait
présenter un email
juger juger ça me plairait bien sûr une
émission de talents quelque chose comme
ça on ne voyait toujours je pense qu'on
est anglais ni anti six coups on a
toujours des possibilités d'aller plus
loin dans les choses tant que oui enfin
bon idéaux nice
la personne qui pourrait remplacer
catherine à s'asseoir isabelle away ah
oui elle sera bien je maîtrise déjà pas
et c'est moi même donc ça va être
compliqué là bas pourquoi pas jean
michel là j'étais sur place pour voir
aller il faut mettre les deux mains par
terre après un pied et un au pied ils
seront dressées tout doucement on se
remettra rapidement possible qu'en danse
est plus simple même si en même si on se
casse la figure au moins peut on peut se
retrouver assez rapidement et continuer
mais sans gras c'est un peu plus
compliqué